in the Northeast Atlantic Ocean Plankton
populations aren't looking like they
used to these tiny marine organisms have
included an array of datom and
dinoflagellates and copap pods writing
the currents to food and survival but as
ocean waters have gotten warmer the
populations of copap poods and krill
have declined in the summer and at the
center of it all are tiny photosynthetic
bacteria called Picos cyano bacteria
whom may just Outlast us
[Laughter]
[Music]
all CYO bacteria come in many different
shapes and sizes some are simple some
are long and some are just odd to look
at and if we needed just one word to
Define Picos cyano bacteria we would
probably go with small they're generally
0 .2 to around 2 micrometers in length
which makes them small even by bacterial
standards piled together like this they
look like those optical illusion
paintings you're supposed to squint at
to find the hidden image but don't waste
your time pushing your face closer and
closer to the screen there is no picture
hiding amongst these
bacteria well or is
there there are two Genera of Picos
cyano bacteria cynic cacus and
prochlorococcus and together they kind
of rule the world at the very least they
are considered to be the most abundant
photosynthetic organisms on our planet
the abundance of Pico cyano bacteria is
matched by just how geographically
widespread they are that's made them
fascinating for scientists who want to
understand how they managed to spread so
far and how their prevalence has shaped
our planet assembling the history of
picocyanobacteria is a complex
undertaking but it has some delightful
theories like recently scientists came
up with one potential explanation for
how picano bacteria were able to spread
to new parts of the ocean hundreds or
millions of years ago I'm going to bet
that you can't guess how that happened
unless you watched the video our sister
Channel eons did on this topic recently
here's what you need to know first for a
long time Picos cyano bacteria were
thought to be autotrophic meaning they
could only get their food by making it
in their case through photosynthesis but
it turns out their mixotrophs able to
take in elements like carbon through
other sources including it seems a
material found in arthropod skeletons
called kiten and scientists looking at
the evolution of Picos cyano bacteria
came to an interesting conclusion that
the pyano bacteria might not just have
been eating kitan from ancient bug-like
creatures they might have actually been
setting sail on them cruising around on
an edible boat made of discarded body
parts as as they began their slow but
immense takeover of the ocean an
expansion that would see them become
responsible today for around
25% of all photosynthesis in the
[Music]
ocean this kitan raft hypothesis
provides one possible story for how
pyano bacteria spread around the world
but prochlorococcus and caus did not
accomplish what they have accomplished
just by spreading they also had to adapt
at any given point in time their
survival is linked to a myriad of
factors the availability of nutrients
the amount of light they're getting the
temperature of the water and the fact
that every organism around them is also
attempting to survive the same
conditions adaptation isn't a challenge
unique to Picos cyano bacteria after all
but they are very very good at it
they're so good that it's difficult to
summarize their abilities because they
have adapted to so many different
conditions in so many different ways so
let's just focus on one example Sina
cacus are found in warm and cold Waters
alike which is challenging for organisms
like picoso bacteria because
photosynthesis is a very temperature
sensitive process and yet sakas have
managed to be found in waters as cold as
2° C by altering the behavior of their
FICO bilisim a protein complex that acts
like an antenna to harvest the sunlight
part of the job of the FICO bism is to
regulate the amount of light that the
cell receives it makes sure that the
cell gets enough for photosynthesis but
not so much that the organism will
accumulate a dangerous amount of
reactive oxygen species as
byproducts one of the ways that CA cacus
limits the amount of light transmitted
by the FICO bilisim is through a
molecule called orange carotenoid
pigment which turns excess light into
heat the orange carotenoid protein isn't
limited to the pyano bacteria and in
fact not all sanaka species produce it
many of the warmer weather species don't
even have a gene for it but for those
species living in colder Waters the
protein is part of their survival
allowing them to adapt to a niche that
would otherwise be
unwelcoming so we saw one way that
picocyanobacteria have spread and one
way that they have adapted but that
isn't sufficient to describe their
history cuz not only do they travel and
adjust they also compete
putting their adaptations to use quickly
when conditions change around them with
consequences for the species that share
their home CA cacas can rapidly allocate
resources towards photosynthesis as
water is warm allowing them to
potentially out compete other organisms
so as climate change continues to see
the warming of oceans perhaps picoy
bacteria will continue their dominance
in fact we're seeing it already in the
Krill and copot population that have
declined over the years in the Northeast
Atlantic Ocean where Rising temperatures
have been affecting the ecosystem in a
number of ways including through Picos
cyano bacteria because along with their
talent for harvesting light one of the
other advantages that Picos cyano
bacteria is their small size it makes
them able to bring in so many more
nutrients relative to their tiny bodies
compared to other Plankton and in turn
that helps them reproduce and survive
especially as temperatures change and
affect those nutrient levels that's
great news for
picocyanobacteria and terrible news for
copap pods because the other Plankton
the larger ones that struggle to get as
many nutrients those are what the copap
pods like to eat not pyano bacteria
which are just too small and lacking in
nutrients so as the population of
non-pos cyanobacteria Plankton goes down
so too does the population of copap PODS
and krill and this in turn affects us in
a lot of ways through the basic
geochemical cycles that serve as the
foundation for our planet to the fishing
industries that provide people's
livelihoods and food and scientists
predict that the global population of CA
cacus will go up by around
14% by the end of this Century does that
mean Picos cyano bacteria will win who
knows there are other organisms and not
to mention entire ecosystems that
surround the picocyanobacteria and that
shape their success but also what does
it mean to win in a world where the
demands of survival are always in
[Music]
flux thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us and remember if
you like to learn about pyano bacteria
and their kitan raft Adventures you can
head over to youtube.com/ eons to see
their episode about it the folks on the
screen right now they are our patreon
patrons there're a bunch of people who
individually could not make this show
happen but when they all work together
like maybe a bunch of bacteria in the
ocean doing 25% of the world's
photosynthesis they can make really
amazing and big things happen like the
existence of this entire Channel and its
entire multi-year history thank you so
much to all of them if you would like to
become a patreon patron you can go to
from our master of microscopes James
Weiss you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere
nearby